yes indeed the regulations pretty much
why won't talk about tomorrow yeah this
is lovely because it's such a valuable
award 2105 a sit down beside you over
here for so many years we've been so
identify fans because everybody what
what do you say to everybody loves you
for beginners and they're all for some
file from the Oklahoma soda chase me
about every year with a new every new
generation child has to go to seven
physics to be civilized I don't know why
beginners is just as an extraordinary
good life a little movie showed and I've
seen through
are you surprised but the further that
this film has given you so much
attention and you want all these award
we were surprised a little bit because
the film has not been seen by a
tremendous amount it open so so long ago
didn't draw in episode
flurry of movies are not taking place up
to
Academy Award so I'm is absolutely
amazing and it just winning it I hope
that helped helps fulfill be seen again
these awards editing for your career at
this point I mean a you are you getting
on even getting more work than what I am
but I'm gonna have to because I was
croaking in the next for you I'm going
to do something for you record scratch
total behaviors what what did you do to
personify this time for almost anyone in
the world record yeah the whole crew was
good yeah he was in this character for
self clear Michael Michael tada that's
was all about it's a true character and
he be written in with such affection and
such a lack of self pity I was funded
made me so relaxed
the one toxic abington he relates Muslim
less talent who a humor I think his
marvelous humor against all odds jujitsu
lesson to everyone
cancer and diet you treat
every kind of
at all westward is different from
receiving all these awards this year yes
isn't it boring yes it is fun
crazy about the red carpet I have a so
grateful a lot of award night's race
emergence you'll see a gray carpet one
of the me having a good time
oh god yes it's perfect if they're going
into this incredibly horrific profession
they better love every minute of it
otherwise don't you know just quit what
you can did you decide to take this part
because he was so it was so well written
and so human
there can be no other
your book of memories is really
wonderful sometimes I
page and divinity
Lord my orders are you planning this
right and all that
oh I'd like to write another book but
not about me this time that's that's
tough divided like yourself no I'd love
to run another book thank you for
offering upstaged by cosmo
we had a little private talk that you
now that you mentioned in Cosmo and
buggy I think our Cosmo was
it was just a trickster I'm going so
thank you thank you